close that out
okay
all right we got it all right
sweet
very cool do you think we should put
this light on though yeah let me try
this
is that better
sort of
we're dark we're in the dark that's okay
that's right in the dark i guess that's
where it's supposed to be okay all right
you want to fire it up all right great
so we're here with jack marchetti it is
25 hours let's just say 24 20 24 is more
dramatic okay all right
until
yeah until uh
until judgement day
yeah until the the conclusion
of uh four of a kind campaign on
kickstarter and uh we have the pleasure
of speaking to you what time is it there
in chicago
jack it is 107.
okay great all right and uh have you
been getting a lot of sleep the last
couple weeks jack
uh a lot less um ever since i moved in
with my girlfriend like i've gotten
i used to be a crazy night owl i used to
be up to like three or four in the
morning and then the minute we moved in
together like 10 o'clock i'm i'm out you
know but that that happened in case much
uh
lately or whatever so but i haven't i
don't think i've been bad as lucas i
think lucas i think actually might
be worrying more than i am which is kind
of funny but you know
so you so you're not worried right now i
mean we you know you've i mean you've
been able it's been impressive you've
been able to raise over you know i think
what is it over almost 37 thousand
dollars to this point
but but now we have to double the amount
that you've raised
in the next 24 hours so and you say
you're not nervous
well i mean
i don't know
like
um i wouldn't say i mean i'm not
like oh it's no problem it's gonna
happen you know so but it's it's one of
those like
maybe it's the it's part of like you
know when you're young and you're told
by some point you're going to be blind
you kind of take things into perspective
a little bit so
um
i mean i'm i wouldn't say i'm worried or
nervous i mean if it happens great if it
doesn't happen there's always another
way um hopefully it does hopefully
um because like you said we have to
raise like 120 of we've raised in 38
days in like one day um but other
projects have done it and you know why
not us so um
hopefully around
11 30 central time tomorrow i'll be
doing the johnny drama victory thing
and if not um you know back to the
drawing board yeah man we know we hope
so too jack you know we definitely hope
so too we can can you talk about
the day i mean do you remember the day
when you were a little boy
um where where you know you were given
this diagnosis and you were told that
one day you would be blind
yeah so
the way it worked was my mom never
really i didn't really know
that i had like this debilitating
disease until i was 13. i was diagnosed
when i was six
i just had no idea what what that meant
um
i i went to two pretty world-renowned
south like eye doctors every year twice
a year and i just thought cool i get i
get out of school twice a year
um and it never really dawned on me that
you know something really weird was
going on like they're doing blood work
on me you know they're hooking my eyes
up to like electrodes and things like
that to do ekgs and things like this all
just seem completely normal to me and i
just figure
i just have bad eyesight um it wasn't
until
i went and got contact lenses
and they couldn't correct me to 2020
and he got really pissed at me for not
reading the 20 20 line and yelled at my
mom and said you know your songs aren't
mature enough for contacts
and i'm like
all right you know sorry and my mom
yelled at him i was like he's got
cornrow district for you jackass that's
why you can't see the
see the 2020 line i was like okay i'm
like what the hell is conrad dystrophy
and you know obviously there wasn't
google back then and so that was when my
mom basically said look you have this
you have this condition
um it's not as bad as
at least she was under the assumption of
the time it's not as bad as uh what's
the worst kind which is called retinitis
pigmentosa um
but it was basically at that point where
it's like you know if you
if you get through puberty
you might have a shot at
um
keeping at least some semblance of
normal vision because a lot of people
get diagnosed with this and a year later
they're blind or you know some if it's
the
unknown nature of it is what really kind
of sucks with it because you know i made
it the third i'm like good you know i'm
i can still see pretty well in
comparison and that was around the time
where my brother's vision just
like his was always better than mine and
then bam he was
bumping into things like 20 times more
than usual and like stopped driving
stopped he couldn't really work anymore
he went out on disability and you know
he's only three years older than me so
you know
it's just you know kind of one of those
things where
um
you know i've dealt with it so long
that
you know i kind of came to terms and
grips with it a long time ago like i
stopped having a pity party for myself
like a long time ago because it's like
no one's you know
um
it's it's one of those like control the
things you can control
um
and trying to just deal with the rest
and there's
nothing they can do about it so
um there's really no point in like
dwelling on it which
i've noticed
i mean because it sucks right i mean
you're going you're going blind right
it's one of the senses you kind of
really really want to hold on to so
really sucks but you know i kind of came
to grips with it a long time ago and it
you know there's there's no point in
kind of dwelling on it at this point so
we'll answer your question
and jack does anyone else in your family
have this besides your brother
uh my mom is a carrier okay um
however she's second generation irish i
believe
so
they've never found anyone else that had
it so my only guess is that there was
someone in ireland that was a relative
of ours that
probably was bumping into things and
they just assumed was a drunk and that's
why he was bumping into things as
opposed to having you know a retinal
disease or something along those lines
but no we've never found
anyone else that has uh
has the same condition now yeah you know
and and jack i mean how how often
is it is it a daily thing is it an
hourly thing is it a weekly thing how
often does it kind of flash through your
mind and you sort of deal with like
you know when one day sort of this whole
world that i see is going you know i'm
not going to see this world anymore how
often does that hit you
i think if i thought about it as often
as i think some people think i might
think about it i'd go crazy
um
i tried like i
it's like one of those like i said
probably some point in my teens i was
like you know what if it happens it
happens if it doesn't it doesn't i'm
going to try and enjoy
i'm going to try and enjoy life and
whatever happens as long as i can see it
and then
you know
you know the lights go out or whatever
uh you know deal with it then um
but i try not to think about it probably
in so like
because there's nothing i can do about
it it would be one thing it was like
you know
if i was like a heavy smoker still and
my doctor was like you need to if you
quit smoking you're gonna you're gonna
you know improve or potentially
uh
you know um you'll be able to maintain
vision longer and my dumb ass was still
smoking or something like that and then
i'd probably keep thinking like oh i
need to quit i need to quit whatever
like
time ago so
i mean it's just not something that i
spend
an enormous enormous amount of time
thinking about just because i mean it's
kind of always been there
and
just
you know i just try not to dwell on it
now
when i'm like walking into like a dark
bar or a dark restaurant or
when like co-workers want to go out for
drinks or something like that then it
becomes like i i kind of can't because
it's really
it's the only time i really feel
handicapped when i'm in like a dark bar
or a dark restaurant and it's always
weird when you have to ask your
co-worker like dude can you walk me to
the bathroom you know it's just kind of
strange things like that that you just
kind of i just
like
it just
made me feel uncomfortable so i just
never i just kind of like you know what
you guys enjoy go
until someone finds me like a bar that's
not dark but my my idea of what dark is
this is probably what your idea of dark
is is probably drastically different or
whatever so a lot of people like it's
bright in here and i'm like i can't see
a damn thing so
um
so yeah
do your co-workers know about the
campaign and they know about the whole
story i mean how much oh yeah
oh yeah they i work in an ad agency
so part of me thought i'm like this cool
i work with a bunch of people that know
how to get the word out and i was like
this is going to be great
and it worked a little bit um
i think a
a big assumption that i think i had and
i think a big assumption that lucas that
were two that both he and i had that
just didn't come true at all one was
kind of local media like
perhaps like the local i mean chicago
has two major newspapers it's a pretty
big media market i figure and they're
pretty big on when people
like local people do film stuff because
we're not really known for film stuff
and i was like i'm pretty sure
some of them would be interested in this
and it turned out to not be not be the
case at all and we reached out and just
no one was really
interested
and then the second thing was
like
charities for the blind like this would
be a really kind of feel interesting
story i think that
um like a charity set up to help kind of
people like me
who are then you know trying to maintain
as much independence as possible things
like that going on fulfilling a dream
while you still can and they
kind of had no interest in it either my
only guess would be
either hey they just didn't like the
idea or um they didn't like the fact
that
the fundraising aspect of it that's my
only guess i mean i don't really know
um
but so yeah so i mean i had
uh like a bunch of people that i did
work with reach out to
you know there's there's like a site
called agency spy which is kind of like
not really dmz but it's kind of like
that for advertising it's like everyone
goes to agency spy to like kind of get
the
nuts and bolts on what's going on in the
industry and they did a really nice
piece on me which which was kind of how
a lot of the people i work with found
out about it because
i didn't want to send out a mass emails
hey everyone look at my kickstarter give
me five bucks i kind of hoped that they
would find it organically and so that
was like they saw me on agency spying
like dude what the hell are you doing on
agency spy i'm like read the article and
so they read the article and like that
day
like you know people i i didn't even
know i worked with came by and they're
like oh because we had a pretty big big
expansion about a year ago but um really
came by like oh great work on that and
like you know my inbox was flooding with
people giving me hundreds of dollars and
it was pretty surreal or whatever i mean
you guys have gone through kickstarter
so you know how it is when like someone
you've never heard of is like here's 500
bucks and it's like
like cool you know so
yeah now yeah we know yeah we're going
through right now i mean our you know we
you know our
we're releasing goodbye promise and in a
way that we haven't seen yet before and
and so our you know our email is is you
know it's every so often we're getting
those notifications and those emails
coming in you know so right um yeah so
we're going through the same experience
all over again you know along with you
you know let's talk a little bit about
about your passion for movies you know
when when did you fall in love with
movies
i mean
probably the the first movie i fell in
love with was the warriors
um
the game movie or whatever from that set
in new york or whatever and i think my
cousin just i watched it with one of my
cousins a billion times or whatever
um but i'm a pretty left-brained person
you know i'm a software developer by
trade
very math science
brother was always the
english guy he has his degree in english
he could write circles around me um
but i always kind of geared towards math
science engineering
and
so i never really
thought for a moment about
this is tom talking about like maybe in
like my teens or whatever about possibly
you know getting into writing or things
like that because
you know i'd rather do a math equation
than write a paragraph usually
so
um
i think it was probably reservoir dogs
i watched that movie so many goddamn
times
uh going through like my senior year
high school and then into college and i
just watched that over and over and over
again and i'm like how like that's
something i i'd want to do i'd want to
try and write something like that
and uh
so yeah i mean it was probably then that
um maybe a few later i downloaded
uh
movie magic screenwriter
and it was like a trial version or
whatever and i wrote 25 pages of
something that were just utter crap i
didn't know there were other crap at the
time but got through 25 pages
and it was like the free trial has
expired
it was like 250 bucks to buy and at that
point i'm like if i don't buy this i'm
not gonna keep writing
so i bought it and then finished my
first script which was awful um i think
almost everyone's first script is
usually pretty awful
and then scrap that one wrote another
one
scrap that one and then i wrote four of
a kind which was the
my third attempt at writing a writing a
script it was probably the first
script that
um
i felt i was telling a story as opposed
to just writing cool scenes
and uh that's probably why out of
anything i've ever written this is the
one that
i probably want to make or at least see
the most just because
it was kind of the
the
i wouldn't say the lightning bolt moment
but it was the first first thing i ever
wrote that that ever got any sort of
validation or vindication or was the
first thing i ever did it was like you
know what you should probably this is
something you'd be good at
um
so but yeah going back to like what got
me into movies or whatever why i
got interested in movies i blame quentin
tarantino and reservoir dog
i mean i'm just fascinated by the whole
just you know just being like left brain
and
just
i mean you see you work 40 hours a week
at this at the sad agency is that right
you
you have sort of a daily routine you do
all that
and then and on the side then you want
this sort of wild filmmaking journey
and and
yeah it's like
like kind of what happened is
um
i i entered the script in green light
and then when that didn't
when when we didn't when it
didn't uh happen or whatever that was
like well i gotta go become a
software developer now because that's
what i got my degree in
and
so i went and was like well
you know i'll go spend the next couple
of years getting really good at that and
that's basically what i ended up doing
so
um
and every so often i would come back and
work on the script
and then work on others along the way
and uh so yeah so yeah by by trade yeah
i write basically code all day um
which is kinda like i could not like i
could probably never see myself writing
a novel just because
it just seems like i don't know i just
can't wrap my head around like being
that descriptive and writing like that
like i love the fact that i can type
interior bar night and everyone knows
what i'm talking about i really need to
go into details what's in the bar or
whatever and the fact that like
a screenplay has almost a syntax to it
kind of like like when you're writing
code
if you miss a
semicolon somewhere it's not going to
compile it's not going to work right so
there's a syntax you have to follow and
i kind of like
how
a screenplay is almost i mean it's not
like code by any means but it's got a
structure and a syntax to it that just
like my analytical
left brain mind just was like i'm gonna
eat that up
so
um so yeah so that's probably why i get
there towards screenwriting as opposed
to you know long-form novel writing so
my brother does that he writes that he's
trying to write a novel and i read like
his prose and i'm like that's just
gorgeous that i will never be able
to write like that like i need to just
write interior bar or exterior parking
lot and the way he's just able to
you know get words together or whatever
just blows me away probably follows him
away that i can get a computer to you
know enter a few commands and
you know whatever you want so
you know some kind of work
he and i actually worked on a script
together which was really interesting
and i basically told them like look you
write it in word
write
long form very detailed and i'll take
what you did
and take like you know three paragraphs
and condense it down into three action
lines because for some reason he can't
seem to do that he overwrites everything
right so i'm going to work well together
and
you know uh
yeah you know hopefully um
you know if
if this does or doesn't work
um i'm assuming i'll still because he
has no interest even i think if he had
good eyesight his vision was still uh
functioning properly um he had no
interest in like directing whatsoever
he's like
it's all you know no thanks i had no no
interest in that although it was kind of
funny when
uh
he had brought up like i have no
interest in ever directing anything and
then we were working on a script
together and he's like you know if this
ever gets made you know i want them to
stay fine like this and the trailer
should be like this and this should be
like that i'm like that's called
directing right he's like oh maybe i
would like it you know it's kind of
funny so um but yeah we kind of worked
well together um ever since we moved
apart from each other because when we
lived together we just beat the out
of each other all the time as brothers
kind of do
well that was i was going to ask you
where is he living now is he in illinois
or
yeah he lives he lives action on the far
south side of chicago in a neighborhood
called um so he's actually in chicago
proper in the actual city i live just
outside the city limits in a suburb
called riverside but we both grew up you
know in the same in the same
neighborhood in the city for you know
about 30 years
okay
how did you meet lucas how did you get
involved with lucas
when i was
kind of looking around at other
kickstarters or just kind of googling
around like what
i think
the search term was probably something
along the lines of like
do narrative films
raise as much money as doc energies
because then my
my first thought was
documentaries will always raise more
money than a narrative film because
there's somewhat of a cause built in
because there's somewhat of like a cause
built in
and so i found one of his articles that
he had written
and the fact that he took like a uh a
data mining approach
and had charts and percentages and
things like that i'm like oh i'll just
eat all this up or whatever
and uh
so he probably can feel like
changed my perception of like what
kickstarters work and which ones don't
and you know
where you should put your dvd as opposed
to something else and things along those
lines and they all kind of
as far as like what succeeds and what
doesn't as far as like are you raising
the full budget are you raising
um
you know just finishing funds the whole
thing documentary shorts or they all
kind of succeed and fail around the same
kind of rate or whatever
and uh so that's kind of how i found him
and i just sent him an email i'm like i
really appreciate i really liked what he
did
blah blah blah
and he's like thanks
you know and then from then on we just
kind of
started talking from there
early on i kind of realized i'm going to
need considering i had absolutely no
following whatsoever i think i had 300
twitter followers maybe
um
and
so i was like i'm gonna need
not necessarily a team but i'm gonna
need someone else like that's gonna come
along for the ride and you know while
i'm
well i'm on a computer all day at work
um which gives me access to like twitter
to do things like that like there's
gonna be days where i'm just not gonna
be able to to give this the full
the full attention it needs during the
daytime and so if i have someone else
out there that's also helping um so
that's kind of how we uh we got in touch
i'm curious what's your take on social
media in terms of how much time you
should put into something because you do
spend
eight hours maybe plus on the computer
and i know for me when i've had jobs
doing that the last thing i want to do
when i come home
is sit at the computer
and and deal and face it you know i want
to be doing something where i'm moving
around so how do you feel about that
because so many people think it's a
necessary evil if you want to call it or
a fun thing whatever it is
in terms of
creating a presence online
well i'm a complete computer nerd
obviously so i'm completely comfortable
sitting 20 hours a day
this was like i'm like i'm all for it
i'm like i never leave the seat right i
should really invest in like a stand-up
desk or else i'm gonna be obese in a few
years so
um so i didn't mind that at all just
because if i'm not on my computer i'm on
my phone or i'm on my laptop or i'm on
my ipad
so i'm always i'm always connected and
may somebody call it an addiction
whatever i just you know it's kind of my
job or whatever um but just i mean just
in general regarding like social media
um
like i'm sure you guys have seen like
the like the kickstarter dashboard that
shows you
you know the referral website
and the percentage
the amount of backers you've gotten
their total funds the total you've
gotten from them the percentage and
things like that and that kind of
fit into what i figured ahead of time
insofar as people with a direct link to
without any refer referral site have
given the most then there's facebook
which has given uh
um the most money and then there's
twitter which is given i think the most
backers but the smallest amount insofar
as like the the social the
the social media site it makes sense
because facebook i typically try and
only become facebook friends with people
i sort of know so these are people that
would more be willing probably to give
you money than say a stranger on on
twitter would so
there's that aspect of it which kind of
fit into what i kind of figured was
going to happen anyways but but yeah but
i'm completely fine with sitting in
front of a computer all day as i
basically have
since i since i got my first like candy
when i was 10 years old so
and zach i mean you said so what this
has been 38 days so far
is that right yeah and so here we are
we're down to the last day
uh any regrets
um
the only thing i think i
part like
i wouldn't call it a regret maybe a
strategy shift maybe
was
i remember in my early talks with lucas
and
um one of my first videos that i put
together i didn't mention being blind at
all i didn't i didn't want to mention it
period
and
there was a little blurb at the bottom
where i mentioned that i had conor odd
dystrophy because at that moment in time
i thought
people might see this link from a
charity for the blind website come to
this watch a video and i never mention
it at all
and
um they might be like oh is he like why
didn't he mention it so lucas was like
you may want to lead off with that
that's kind of a big thing so
i ended up i think
maybe focusing too much on
this is a camping about a kid going
blind or not kid but about a guy going
blind as opposed to maybe if i would
have focused a little bit more on
this is someone who
is going blind who's gonna make a really
good movie and possibly
add more about
um like the film and things like that
earlier on
um because i sort of started to do that
later on but
it wasn't really
um
like a centerpiece of
like our early um strategy if you will
um
so maybe that i don't know if that would
have had
any big difference or whatever it might
have moved the needle slightly um
but
you know who knows this point but no i
don't have any regrets at all
you know what what gives you the
confidence that this that this is going
to be that kind of movie you know what
what what gives you the confidence to
say like you know what i can make a
really great effort movie
uh i don't know a delusion
um i don't know i mean
it's a
i think kevin smith once said like look
all i can do is make movies that i want
to see and hopefully other people are
kind of like me and they'd want to see
him too
and
i don't know it's it's it's i've written
like six six or seven full-length
scripts and this is by far my favorite
one and anytime i come back to it and
read it
i'm always like
it's almost like reading being
reacquainted with a long lost friend and
you know it still makes me laugh at the
times when it should make me laugh it
still makes me pissed at the times when
it should make me pissed so
the blueprint is there
um
like i think george clooney one like
said you know you can you can make a bad
movie from a good script but you can't
make a good movie from a bad script or
something like that you know what i'm
trying to say
and uh so i think the blueprint is there
um as far as like would i be able to
take that bit like take that
take what's in my head and then
relay that to other people including
actors crew and be like this is like my
vision
that was the thing that that
um
probably like would have kept me up at
night the most um just because i've
never done it before i'd probably be the
most inexperienced person on set i've
never directed actors before i've never
you know commanded a set i don't have
the most like
um
dominating personality i'm a pretty laid
back guy or whatever so
um
i mean
part of me almost even thought like if
we get into like pre-production and it
kind of dawns on me at that point then
maybe directing isn't
isn't the best thing for me i probably
would have thought maybe it wouldn't
have wouldn't have been a bad idea to
maybe find a co-director or even just
find someone else who might direct it
and you know work closely with me and
i'd produce it um i don't think that
would have happened i think i would have
um like if we make it into like if we
make the goal we get the funding or
whatever we and we you know start
setting up
a schedule and things like that i think
i'd love it and i think i think it'd be
a kick-ass time and you know there's so
many parts in the script that i just
can't wait to see people perform um just
to see if
not only it matches what's in my head as
how they do it but if it even exceeds it
um
so i mean i'd have a a lot of homework
to do and a lot of
uh reading to do and things along those
lines to get to that point but you know
i was all for it
you know so if you if you do you know or
if you do when you do
a reach this goal
um what would be the plan then in terms
of the rollout like how soon before you
plan to be in production
right so
um
one of the things that i remember i
when because one of the things with
kickstarter is
the funds you get the funds you you're
given your technic is technically
considered income it's not considered an
investment right so you technically have
to pay taxes on them
so
um
i met with an accountant and i said look
if i raise this money by september
like do i have to pay taxes by the end
of the year and he's like well unless
you shoot unless you obviously it's you
know if all that goes towards the budget
then no you know you it would all be an
expense and no problem
if you don't shoot it by the end of the
year then yes you will pay taxes on that
and you will pay
um
you know if it's a personal you know if
it's given to you personally you will
pay like you know there's gonna be about
28 of that or something along those
lines goes towards taxes i was like well
that sucks because i was planning on
like we raised it in september i don't
think that's enough time
like and who the hell wants to shoot in
november or december in
chicago
right i don't i mean the story takes
place in
winter time but you can get winter in
march here you know like what it's you
know we can make it look like winter no
i don't want to shoot like two below
weather so i went to a tax attorney and
formed a corporation that would let me
adjust my fiscal year
so that my fiscal year
started in september when i would
receive the money and then i wouldn't
technically have to shoot the film or
uh at least spend the money until
august 2013. so
ideally i'd want to shoot it in
probably
february or march 2013 so that would
give
like five months of reproduction or
whatever um
and so uh so that would have been that
that's the uh
sorry there's a train going by right now
nice to l train yeah i feel like we're
in chicago
yeah yeah i live right right next to the
tracks it's really awesome
so um so yeah so that was a plan to
shoot
um
sometime in february or march
um however one of the other ideas was
like let's say like we raise the money
and we end up with a hundred thousand
and to potentially go out to
um
other private investments say look we
raised this on our own
would you be interested in you know you
kick in like 50 or you kick in 100 you
could get 10 whatever right so we
started going down that path then we
probably would have
extended out
the the start time and then at that
point if we start actually raising
significantly more money than the taxes
i would owed
on kickstarter would have been i mean i
would have the the corporate rate would
have ended up being something along like
ah it's like sixteen percent or
something like that i would have been
which sucks because
amazon gets their cut kickstarter gets
their cut then uncle sam would get their
cut even though all of it would be going
towards
the budget of the film and there's
technically
i'm going to get way into the weeds here
but there's an accounting method
called accrual accounting or whatever
where you can then
expense out or something along those
lines uh for something that hasn't been
produced yet or something along those
lines so that would have been possibly
an option
um but yeah so back to your original
february or march would have been
um if we relied on just the kickstarter
to uh eleven when we started production
nice
you know i guess one thing i wanted to
bring up jack is is is we know that i
guess
you know doing sort of these public
interviews has has been something that
you've resisted you know during this
stretch i'm not sure i mean have you
done any radio or or like video
appearances you have done that already
i haven't done video i done
uh
three or four radio
and one
and there's a radio spot tomorrow on an
fm station here so
but yeah i mean i'll be completely
honest this isn't like something i do
naturally by any means i'm uh i'm the
atypical introverted writer software
developer that
let me sit over here in the background
i'm gonna type away and be clever that
way as opposed to
um you know doing video stuff definitely
not
uh
a natural uh
like the amount of times i had to like
try and do the pitch video
i mean it was kind of ridiculous because
like
ever almost every instance of one just
like just just not a fan of
you know watching myself on video or
anything like that and it's just not
something that comes naturally
so yes it's not them it's not the most
comfortable thing in the world for me uh
to do
no i i hate it myself jack i i can't
stand it you know so
you know for
for our our pitch video that we just put
up you know i was able to capture karen
and gregor and then
and then karen had to help me set up the
camera and she had to leave and i had to
yeah it took me a couple hours you know
and
and she's like you're still going there
i'm like yeah i'm trying i'm trying to
get these thoughts out and i i get
really critical and i
i'm just not a fan of being in front of
the camera myself i'm the same way i
mean i had to leave the house and uh
for a little bit and then it was like
100 degrees out so i'm just like i have
to be in the air conditioning so let me
just go in this back room and hibernate
on the computer and dave was able to
finish it but it's yeah it's hard it's
not easy because
you know we're critical of ourselves and
we're like oh i want to do this over
again and and
so i get it but um you know i commend
you for doing this tonight thank you
yeah it's really nice yeah yeah i mean
it kind of came to like the point where
it's like
um
as far as like one of your questions
about regret or whatever like like the
radio interview i have tomorrow like
part of me is almost like
like do i really want to go on there and
like them say look dude you're like so
far away there's like not a chance in
how you're gonna make this right which
i'm assuming they might bring up or
whatever but just the chance that
one dude who hears it who knows whatever
right you never know what can happen
from it so i didn't want to like end up
like well if i would have done that or
that you know what could have happened
so
so yeah well like you said we've seen it
you know so it
you know and regardless what happens
it's just like you know you you just
take it down to the wire you know i mean
that's
that's what it's all about for us as
well it's just like no matter what
happens
you know it worked out for us where this
particular week
um we had sort of freed up a little bit
on our schedules just because we wanted
to continue to push goodbye promise so
we have we had a little bit more time
this week to devote
to something you know and it was it was
last weekend
where um you know we just really
deliberated it wasn't an easy decision
to say right you know let's put in all
this effort into our own thing
and then you know and to kind of get the
ball rolling
and be like okay
wait a minute you know like yeah you
know we're seeing our guy jack over here
and it's it's looking it's looking like
he needs some help here you know he
needs some he needs some force he needs
something
and and we felt like
you know what maybe maybe we can you
know maybe he still won't reach the goal
but maybe we can create an enough frenzy
so that something comes out of it you
know and so it was a really tough
decision because it's just like you know
what we're doing ourselves is already
impossible you know so then to look at
some things someone else is doing and
saying like man that really looks
impossible too all right let's stop
doing our impossible and let's just put
everything we have into what jack's
doing but it's just like you know what
it's like
the moment the moment we made the
decision and the moment we we we made
the announcement and we got behind it
to some degree it was a big relief on
our end because you know there's so much
pressure that you feel that clock is
ticking you know and it's just like and
you can't stop that that clock from
ticking
and and all of a sudden we were sort of
free from our own deal and we've been
able to take all that energy we have and
anything that we can do and we've put it
toward you and so
that's all we can do is so we'll we'll
go to the wire and we'll send out as
many emails as we can we'll do as many
tweets as we can we'll do as many text
messages we can
just to see how far we can push it you
know because that's the way we like to
live we like to live
going all out giving it everything we
have
right and like
you know i think like i think since you
guys got involved i think we almost
doubled right i mean it was i was at
like 20 with like a week to go and it
was like that was a good showing
or whatever um it was
uh you know a lot more than i
like i set it very high obviously like i
said because i had no interest in making
a 5 000 or 10 000 or whatever
but like
i mean
getting to 20 was like wow i can't
believe i got that hard and then like to
be almost at 40
is like
while it's not a good chance on the
final day to get it being at 40 is
better than being at 20 and it basically
owed that almost entirely to you guys
for i mean like i'm amazed when i like
see my twitter account i'm like
they're like tweeting everyone and like
they're getting attention and and
it's like
you know considering like you got like
the the post up i mean you guys are in
the middle of your own thing and you're
like you're gonna help dude over here
even though it may not work you know
you know
you know you know win or die trying
right and uh
you know i think you know you guys just
exemplify that money and like i said
before like it's people like you
that
you know
it makes the internet a good place
because the internet can be full of full
of and and trolls and things
like that and it's people like you
that
make it worthwhile and make it worth
you know helping other people and i
think it even probably got other like
you know what i'm gonna help
you know on these projects as well or
whatever i think you know there's
there's a big thing when it comes to
paying it forward so and you guys
exemplify that so you know forever for
that i'm forever grateful so thank you
very much oh thank you well you know
even even too jack if you go to this i
don't know where you're doing this radio
interview tomorrow but
whatever happens whether it's a shock
jock who puts you on the spot or or
whether it's a dr phil who's really nice
whatever it is you know you still have a
very unique story and and and whatever
happens there's still
stuff afterward that someone could hear
about it i mean so you so it's not
you know it's still a very unique story
and it's it's interesting how people
have rallied around and
and want to support you so
right there's a
for the tribune that we got in top
chicago tribune which is our second uh
which is probably our biggest uh uh
daily newspaper
and
she got in touch with me like a week and
a half ago or something along those
lines and
we were talking she's like i want to
tell your story
be able to get it in the paper by then
i'm like
you know so
but she still wants to write the story
and i basically said well let's wait and
see like obviously we're still going to
do i'll still let her write the story
but it was let's figure out what the
ending is before because it'd be kind of
stupid if it ended up in the paper like
a week from now
and like oh i hope it still makes it and
we have made it or we don't i'm like
let's know what the ending is and then
figure out
figure out what the article should be
about should it be about you know
succeeding at raising the money or
should it be about
maybe the initial
attempt not working and then not giving
also you know there's the storyteller in
me i guess yeah
yeah well i i hope
you know i hope with our efforts i hope
you know i mean certainly we're going to
go down to the wire with you and i hope
it's um i hope it's more to to have you
get closer like you know actually
pushing you to the goal rather than
pushing you close enough where it builds
up your hope you know
not to make it you know so um yeah you
know but it's just but it's been great
on our end you know just seeing
um so many people in the film community
uh rally behind this story you know and
and kind of what kind of what set off
this conversation here tonight i know we
we try to set up something a couple days
ago and and and we weren't able to make
that happen so we're grateful for this
conversation here
and um you know
you tweeted us
and you basically asked us like what
would you guys do
if you were in my shoes you know in
terms of just going all out you know um
right
you know and that's what kind of spawned
this conversation you know and we and we
responded back like
you know we pretty much do exactly what
you're doing you know it you know you
you started all off with the article you
know i know you said it's kind of corny
but i don't think it's corny but you
know you go big or you go blind you know
and so right
you know you you lay it all out
um
you know you go for it
right yeah and i mean
you know
i had a talk with uh
one of the developers at work or
whatever and uh
and he's like
you know at least you know
you know there's at least you went for
it right you tried you went for it you
know and then at least you know you went
for it that's admirable and then you
know the cynic in me is like
well if i never went for it i still
always thought like like even if it
doesn't happen or whatever i could have
thought well maybe it could have and
i'll just let that sit off to the side
or whatever and just you know think
about that or whatever but you know just
just no way to you know
there's no way to kind of live
forever you know it's like you know go
for it or don't
you know there's no point in in thinking
about doing something and i mean
especially like
for something like i had someone who
asked who told me that i should be doing
this early on in the campaign he sent me
an email saying
you're doing this all wrong
you need to
make a bunch of shorts
submit them to film festivals
um build up your craft and then you
raise the money to do a feature and i'm
like did you watch the video or read
anything and he's like yeah i'm like so
you know that i might be blind in like a
year or two
right i don't really have the time to go
and do shorts or whatever and he's like
oh that's a good point he's like well
good luck i was like
you know or whatever so it's just kind
of funny that the
the things you get when you when you run
a kickstarter or whatever but uh
but yeah so you know
we'll see what happens in
about 23 hours at this point 24 hours
yeah i know you know we i guess we all
we all have to get back to the grind we
got to continue to spread the message um
you know are there any are there any um
closing words yeah closing words or or
you know do you need um do you need
anything we can do or anything like
you're thinking like anything you want
to know from our end do you have any
questions for us or anything like that
the way i've closed every podcast or
radio interview is i basically say if
you have a rich uncle who has ever
thought about producing a film
send him the link
so
hopefully that uh
you know you never know
all right um
well
and just real quick what's what's going
through your mind right now i mean
you're about to go to sleep and then you
have to get up for work tomorrow and is
that right or or yeah
uh i mean
there's a bit of relief
just because it's like
i haven't there hasn't been a day since
i think i've learned what kickstarter
was maybe back in
january i think i didn't i think i
backed someone else's like
project maybe a year ago but i never
really gave any thought to what
kickstarter was
and then the minute i was like well let
let's try this and this was like back in
february when i started thinking about
doing this and when i actually went out
and shot the first thing we did
and so like since february
it's kind of it's kind of been like it's
always there
and
after tomorrow it's kind of gone so
i don't have to think about it anymore
and i don't have to like okay like what
can i write a more
clever tweet that might get someone to
to back the project or am i tweeting too
much or am i annoying the out of my
friends way too much which is probably
why i won't run another one like if this
doesn't work that's kind of it and i'll
probably
try
private investment or just go another
route just because it's like
crap out of everyone i know for the past
like 40 days and i'm sure i mean you
know at the end of the day you know i
don't think i've offended anyone but um
you know i i wouldn't want to just you
know monday set the goal at 50 000 and
let's just do it again you know that's
not going to happen
um
but so there's a sense of like it's
probably almost and this is not even
nearly on their scale but i'm assuming
on election day
obama and romney are probably like thank
you god i don't have to give
another speech today
or whatever it's like it's finally
like we will find out
and then
you know let the chips go like live
where they may so there's a sense of
relief and a sense of you know i mean if
it doesn't happen i'm gonna be
i'm not gonna be happy about it
obviously because you know there's a lot
of work that would into it but i mean
the showing that it got like if it would
have gotten like 50 bucks and no one
would have given a then i really
would have been like well that really
sucks but um
just the amount of like
you know support from like guys like you
or
you know people in general like the the
community in general that i really
wasn't a part of no one had any idea who
i was before the start i mean no one
really knows who i am still but um you
know it's just really cool to see
um you know people get behind you and so
yeah
it's really cool yeah it's awesome and
you deserve it zach you know you know
you really deserve um you know you
you've shown that you have the talent
you've shown that you have the passion
the dedication you know you've put in
the work you know we feel like you
really really deserve your chance
to make this movie you know we just we
just really feel that so
um so we'll stay with it we'll stay with
it you know and so
you know we're kind of hearing from you
that that this that this is the last
stand you know like this this is it you
know these next 24 hours
so let's let's
i definitely won't
um a lot of people have actually said
you should just go set up an indiegogo
and
set the goal for whatever and whoever
was gonna back let them back and i mean
i just you know i
just that the doesn't really
i don't know i just you know i i don't
think
you know it's just not in the plans or
whatever and i have no interest of you
know like i said i'll set the funding
goal for half and launch it again on
monday and set it for 20 days and then
hopefully all 500 and whatever people
are immediately going to give the same
amount because they
i don't think that would happen but you
know i just it was kind of uh
you know take your shot
sometimes you hit home runs you know
babe ruth struck out a lot so um but he
kept coming back to the plate and i'll
come back to the plate just maybe not
through a kickstarter or an indiegogo so
you know we'll see what happens yeah
well
we want to thank you for sharing your
story zach and
and um
yeah you know just as the campaign ends
one way or the other uh that does that
doesn't mean the story ends so you know
you just you just continue to work it
and and we'll just you know we'll we'll
see if there's a greater story at play
or or or whatever the case is going to
be
absolutely man and i appreciate you guys
uh finally getting me on here you know i
know it was a
you know i'm not the
the quickest to say yeah let me get on
video and chat away so
um
you know hopefully i'll see you guys at
the finish line you got it you'll see
you'll see us there jack one more the
other you'll see us there thank you
cool all right we'll talk soon
all right take care all right
bye